When I say scrolling in parallel,
what I'm really talking
about is Parallax Scrolling.
And Parallax Scrolling as in we
have different layers of views
scrolling at different speeds.
It's one way that we create the illusion
of depth in material, and it's really
easy to do with Recycler view when
targeting Honeycomb and above devices.
Now our app will continue
to work on Gingerbread,
just without Parallax Scrolling.
Now we're only going to add this
scrolling into our phone landscape view.
And it's easy to do this by
creating a view that can only be
found in landscape.
Inside of our landscape frag bit main,
we'll rename at bar to parallax bar.
Then inside of our Forecast Fragment
if we find parallax bar and
we're on at least Honeycombe, add an on
scroll listener to our Recycler view.
The cool thing about recycler
view is that it unlike list view
actually returns the delta x or
y scroll.
And this is perfect because we can
use this to set translation y to move
our parallaxview up and down in response
to the scrolling of our Recycler view.
The regular list view does not actually
return you these delta coordinates at
all, and it's somewhat frustrating.